thank you for inviting me it's a
pleasure being here again it seems like
I come here every year
pattern for as long as I can it may be
one or two left and the advantage of
being relatively late in the program is
that some of the stuff I've said I had
to talk about I don't have to on the
other hand much of the brilliant stuff I
was going to say was already said so it
balances out but what I want to do is
talk a little bit generally about vector
borne diseases vector borne zoonosis
climate weather an unsupported
anthropogenic change in general and make
some very obvious points then go talk
about the West Nile virus example and
come back to those plan level points so
you know if you know the many vector
bones or no see if we are talking about
West Nile virus Lyme disease plague
leishmaniasis etc and all of them share
the fact that full transmission to occur
to humans four things have to happen the
vector has to survive the breathable
host has to be present the pathogen has
to be amplified and finally there has to
be opportunities for spillover for
transmissions to humans or domestic
animals or wildlife of interest and for
all those those to take place it's not
that easy and when we want to talk about
what is necessary for it to occur as far
as climate goes a lot of things have to
come together for successful
transmission to take place and that
includes I feel free to do it that
includes temperature and the same in
math talk very well it's not just the
average it's the minimum with the
maximum with the fluctuations the
minimum at night is very important for
heat effect same for rainfall humidity
extreme events which are increasingly
occurring are increasingly important but
the point I want to make is that all of
those parameters are likely to have a
differential impact on the different
aspects of vector-borne zoonotic disease
transmission in fact very likely will go
in different direction so temperature
may have that kind of an effect on a
vector enhanced vector survival but be
very good bad bad for the presence of
reversible host the same for humidity
rainfall and variability which means
it's the impact of specific climate
change
yes or complex climate changes on
infection of reservoir host and of
transmission of disease to humans are
very difficult to predict and then not
only that and again a points was already
well made a that not only are we talking
about climate change but we talk about
increasing climate variability so time
to predict how those changes will impact
the transmission of a vector bones or
gnosis is not a trivial exercise and
then of course we have to talk about the
issue of scale and people have talked
about the global resolution level P we
talked about this and local resolution
level but both temporally and spatially
we are dealing with factors and the
impact on waned on a range of
resolutions going from the inter annual
to the daily and spatially from what's
happening you know within a household or
between individual hosts all the way to
Z biosphere so the question of how will
climate change impact transmission
infection disease is really a question
at least initially of how to relate
global changes to very complex local
processes and I think meta gave a good
example of we are trying to downscale
those changes of global factors no to
explain what is happening locally but
generally I think you know I think we've
moved beyond this oversimplify the
tormal equals bug year the idea that if
we have the temperature goes up we're
going to have more disease and people
ready talking about malaria I don't
think anybody's talking about dengue
today but several of those disease is
transmitted by mosquitoes and by other
vectors have been a major topic of
discussion for the impact of climate
change on transmission some of the early
work and this is work Andre this is a
simple prediction of you know
temperature is going to go up malaria is
going to come back to New Haven to
London to Copenhagen basically
temperature is higher mosquitoes will do
well transmission will take place and
you know perative li early on this was
you know kind of a buked by a nice
article by M David Rogers and Sarah went
off showing that if we look at the
biology
see mosquitoes and really understand
what the Rice's mission of malaria those
changes are actually very hard to
predict and in fact malaria made Europe
in some places may go down in other
places but they're not gonna be drastic
changes in transmission of malaria
because other factors are much more
important determinants Lyme disease
another good example will be many models
both based on climate and a landscape
much as the work was actually done in
today by the group eel the group led by
M Durland and Malia and so was they
modeled by a branch then on a project
distribution of climate based and more
recent work on trying to develop a risk
a risk model or defining low and high
risk areas for M the tick fo
transmission based on a very data-driven
model based on the infected the density
of infected host seeking empty names of
ticks so I want to talk now about our
study of West Nile virus in the Chicago
area and then come back a little bit to
those general points about climate
change or purge any change and then in
transmission Felicis is the study
supported by the NIH ecology of
infectious disease program NIH NSF which
really has been a crucial program in
supporting that kind of research
generally the researcher trying to look
a collage Aesir disease is often to
ecological for NIH and to medical for
NSF I think much of the work reported
heal actually was supported by this
program so they want to send them again
this was a collaborative study I list
all their collaborators later and also
it occurs very much on a local level and
it's an urban study and I think one of
the points that I think a mustard has
already made increasingly we need to
look at urban areas and it's the ecology
of urban areas and applies the classical
ecological approaches to understanding
the urban habitats so West Nile virus of
thinking we already showed a very
similar slide so I think you know
everything about them where's nerve
virus it came to the u.s. in 99 and form
from Israel actually we know exactly
where it came from and if spread very
rapidly throughout the u.s.
and I want to talk about what's happened
in Illinois where it appeared in 2001
only in builds no human cases in 2002
Illinois had the biggest outbreak of
West Nile virus until then it was
surpassed by than in Colorado and
recently in Texas but out of the 884
human cases there were 884 human case of
66 deaths about 25% of all cases
occurred in Illinois and mostly in the
Greater Chicago area then we had two
very quiet years in 2003 2004 we had two
active years again in 2005 2006 which
initially thought would their match 2002
but the never went this high and then we
had quite years until actually 2012
where we had two 45 cases the last time
I checked if we look at the epidemic
curve this is what happened in 2002 the
big year and then 2005 started out
nearly as high but it never went that
far and the many reasons for that are
not going to talk about them too much
but among them is probably increased
immunity among the build and also better
control efforts because we really
learned a little bit about what is
effective against them cure experience
lousy in urban areas I want to point out
that the urban year-over-year the
outbreak heels were hot and dry I'll
come back to that in a minute but that
fits some of the hydrological component
of the of the transfer of the
determinate of transmissions that Jeff
Lee talked about and suicide hydrology I
found is extremely important not only
for West Nile virus but pretty much
every disease I looked at whether we
talk about tsetse flies or ticks om
scenario transmissions to samaya society
seems to be it's important effect or
anything in explaining transmission so
if we talk about the distribution of
same West Nile virus in Chicago there
were two very obvious false I and this
is Lake Michigan the loop would be white
eel Midway Airport is white eels the one
area just south of Midway Airport and
Northwestern University is here this is
the Evanston Skokie fall site
as an aside in 1975 there was a st.
Louis encephalitis outbreak again
referee dimension it is closely related
to West Nile virus transmitted by the
same mosquitoes using builders relabel
host and the focus here was nearly
identical this is the new focus one of
the questions we haven't really answered
yet is but this is the B this is a
really good areas for transmission of a
mosquito-borne disease but what change
between 75 in 2002 that this new focus
came into place I wish we'll be able to
answer that we haven't really yet so if
we look at the distribution of West Nile
virus human cases in the Greater Chicago
area in 2002 again this is a southern
focus of Midway this is the northern
focus one thing that we've obvious is
that all of this area is in Chicago Lake
plane it is readily flooded in fact
hysteria was loudly developed after the
second world war with the baby boom and
a big building of houses when I want to
avenge those slides to some
veterinarians in Chicago who said Oh
we'll remember this was basically a
swamp nobody really lived here
so clearly the way it is a problem means
standing water the problem means we have
good conditions for development of em
mosquito larvae and transmission so if
we try to do any classification of the
urban landscape based on the urban
characteristics of housing vegetation
social economics and land use we found
out we decided we could divide the urban
area into five different types and the
type one type was clearly the area where
we had most human cases we call it urban
type five housing developed in the 40s
and 50s but moderate covers of
vegetation moderate population density
those are kind of I would say
blue-collar suburbs I would characterize
those areas and you can see that really
the vast majority of the space Brazil
there were not many cases in the very
you know is a downtown area and not as
many cases is a much better forested
suburban area I want to say that much of
the smoke
led by Marilyn Louise a medical
geographer at the University of Illinois
one thing that was very interesting that
we found out is that around Zoe's
housing there were a huge numbers of
storm drains that nobody knew about in
fact in the area south of M south of em
Midtown south of Midway Airport they
found 3,000 of those storm drains in
people's backyards basically apparently
it used to be alleys between the houses
and gradually maybe people moved the
fences took them over they became part
of the lawn and those are perfect
habitat for Hewlett pipiens I mean you
have standing water you have grass
clippings you have live little if you
like you'll experience you love you
really cannot ask for anything better
just good as it gets
and what happens is that in I think hot
years are obvious in hot summers
everything moves much faster muscular
develops developed much faster
transmission amplification all of that
one of the question was why our dry
summers apparently more suitable for
transmission and that was the case in
the 99 outbreak in M New York and also
in the 2004 outbreak in M Colorado I
think it was 2004 and one of the things
that happens during dry years especially
after good with spring rains and again
coming back to what Jeff Lee was talking
about the different patterns of
precipitation in parts of the country
you have good spring blames what is
accumulating and then the motor leader
standing zero if you have frequent heavy
rains in the summer the lot of we get
flushed away so really what you want is
dry hot summers followed by following
wet Springs and that seems to be a busy
pattern at least in the Northeast
Midwest up to the mountain region I
guess it's different in the northwest of
Scelzi different in Florida okay so if
we want to we want to go a little bit
final and trying to relate the spatial
pattern of transmission to very local
conditions again the idea is that we
really have to understand what is
happening locally in order to find to
figure out how those local conditions
less to give us the original picture so
we'd sleep there we had many research
questions but three of them are inter
annually what are the conditions
associated with higher mosquito
infection in some years within the year
what temporal characteristics of
rainfall and temperature precede changes
in mosquito infection and what were the
tempo a leg and then spatially can be
used at patterns of rainfall and
precipitation to explain differences
even within a relatively M narrow area
and the work was done in the Greater
Chicago area Cook and DuPage County up
here so if we look at the mosquito
infection weight with Mal by week 4m the
5-year period of 2004 to 2008 and here
are 12 2005 and 2006 will be well the
years we had high high transmission in
comparison to 2004 7 & 8 what is what
has been noted in every year actually
regardless of the level of transmission
that amplification of virus occurs
relatively rapidly and always about the
same time the last week or two of July
the first week of to of August is when
amplification happens and that seems to
hold and that seems to be the pattern in
much of the country actually again I
don't know what Florida but it certainly
was expect pattern in the Northeast and
marked or surprised also the pattern in
Atlanta I maybe talk about that briefly
if I have time we know the temperature
will affect the speed of the different
processes that passage and replicate
faster mosquitoes will have a shorter
time between blood meals and in general
that if the winter is warmer more
vectors will overwinter and that's
important because we're seeing that West
Nile virus overwinters in mosquitoes as
far as precipitation provides you know
good vegetation provide resting areas
for the mosquitoes provide standing
waters and in general moisture levels
humidity are extremely important for
mosquitoes in other disease variables so
what we did we didn't exploratory
analysis describing the mosquito
infection weight and their risk factors
precipitation and temperature we try to
cull
call a time lag correlation between
weekly degree between the Glee week
precipitation and the BM meaning section
wait with then with temporarily
temporarily we developed a model to
forecast the weekly am I are using
weather data using the you year 2004 to
2007 and tested in 2008 and again more
recently and then spatially we use
regression to and when the force
analysis to develop spacious spatial
model of them infection using weather
and other environmental factors so this
is again I'll study earlier and then
what we have is relatively rich database
for precipitation and temperature we had
them in the US Geological Survey between
1841 station will hit the Illinois State
water Survey and we had the M NOAA
North stations as well so we had
relatively good coverage for temperature
and precipitation and then we had
mosquito death data test data based on
them
the data collected by the Lloyd Illinois
Department of Public Health form M over
350 traps over the five years in the two
counties and they collected between you
know seventy five hundred and ten
thousand mosquitoes eleven songs give us
each vo so what we did is we developed a
spatial database we divide the area into
hexagons of two thousand hundred meters
SL Geographic units and so each hexagon
we summarized the weather and the
mosquito infection weight and
characterize the environmental factors
of that we knew characterize the urban
areas of elevation vegetation status
housing age ways etc we use them as the
abnormals the difference values for
analysis for example look at the
difference between the normal weekly Mir
and the observed amount the difference
between the normal was the observed
weekly precipitation and we found out
that the degree week was a good way to
use temperature data and then we use
both slow and low and smooth data for
three weeks and five week average so
what we find out that mosquitoes
affection and this is the data showing
that in 2002 we had a relatively high
number of - of human cases and the
degree week at week 35 which i think is
mid-august was also relatively high
again it was a rich it was higher also
in 2005-2006 compared to the yield for
which means-- infection wait a number of
human cases was relatively low if we try
to correlate mosquito infection with
cumulative temperature as a degree week
we found out that the correlation was
maximized as the base temperature of 22
degrees and a one-week leg so will it
not melt very much of a leg actually
starts prediction with nice if it was
later but you know we looked at their
degree week different from average by
week two is very obvious it was you know
relatively high transmission years of
two thousand to five and six
definitely the difference was much
higher than in other years where
transmission was much less so the best
linear regression model that will give
that we came up with included other than
the auto regressive models
so within degree week of M the
temperature and the Android
precipitation a year ago actually that
was the best prediction we didn't find
much with more recent temperature and in
fact when we M developed a mosquito
infection focusing model it worked
pretty well but it's about two weeks in
advance so the question of how useful it
is remains to be seen but at least we
feel like locally we are pretty good at
understanding what is happening when we
M looked at mosquito infection using the
observed data and the spatial model
estimated data
it's a predictive model it's not bad I
mean when you compare those two graphs
we feel like you know the infection will
predict by the random forest model using
all the variables for the same time
period was pretty good in predicting it
again very short-term prediction so what
we learned is that weekly weather and mi
are both very the course a study area
and across time and varied very finely
and I'm a big believer in going to very
fine spatial resolution but at some
point I'm now and I kind of said let's
go find it let's go find at at some
point
time feel like maybe we have gone too
fine I mean you know I can't make a meth
it would be a big SM fine what I am
mapping so the question is that when do
we actually stop what is the optimal
resolution that is still useful for us
to make prediction but is not
unrealistic as far as collecting the
data M we found that early season dry
conditions did not consistently lead to
increase them infection that was
different than what was available in
Florida and we found a high correlation
between the hyal degree weak and low
precipitation but the degree we the
degree weak was the best term predictor
and temporal in general temporally was
the most important precipitation was
more important explaining spatial
differences but we really do feel that
the microclimate and again that is echo
what temp
Matt was answering especially in
response to a question the microclimate
conditions are really important you know
the mosquito is experiencing you know
not what is observed at even veritably
find net of fair weather stations it's
observed whoops
it's observing what is happening you
know in the vegetation in the pool if
it's allowed we under the tree etc so we
really have and we found also this high
degree of variability even in virus
genetically turistic s-- over a very
final resolution so again I'm stuck with
the questions of how fine we need to go
I saw this like was actually a public
assembly talking about you know what is
happening to the weather so this is one
prediction by somebody from the Illinois
natural history survey what will it what
would be the weather in Illinois in M -
in the end of the century it should be
more like Texas that was kind of funny
to see okay so this is an Athena study
that was done by a lot of people they
it's ii EAD grant is led by tony goldwyn
ability of wisconsin
network of Michigan State University
Mellon with University of Illinois and a
large number of other people that have
been part of this same study I don't
have time to talk too much about what is
happening in em in Georgia but in
Georgia since I moved there in 2008 I
figure let's go
and look at what's happening with West
Nile virus in Georgia and one of the big
question and it's still a big question
oops why is transmission in Georgia so
low in fact until the field the question
was why is transmission in the south so
low I think most of us in West Nile
virus came to the US and you've asked us
to predict where it will do really well
he probably would have said New Orleans
you know Miami
uh no Montgomery delyth etcetera that
has not been the case of course this is
change because this year we had this
really big outbreak in Texas more than
in Dallas more than more than anywhere
you know more than ever before but it
did not happen in Georgia did not happen
in Alabama so still I mean I don't know
what is the matter with Texas but that
one is really kind of and the one thing
I want to say nobody to my no it's
predicted that you know people have been
trying to develop models for West Nile
virus and how it will do in different
countries I haven't heard of anybody
saying there'll be a lot of West Nile
virus in Texas this year of course now
we have you know Williams to explain to
have help people say that the weather in
Texas actually was relatively
comfortable this year while the weather
in Chicago was not so actually it was
about the same temperature in Chicago
which means every in Texas went out and
celebrated never in Chicago stayed home
and wouldn't go out but that's a retro
some retrospectively retroactively
explanation so what happened in Georgia
is that we never had more than 60 cases
per year in compared to the 800 that we
had in EM 2002 and the over 200 that we
had in 2006 m56 and 2012 so we don't
know what's the answer in fact that's
one of the our main research emphasis is
trying to explain what is different in
them in them in the Atlanta area and we
have some ideas you know it's not the
mosque in no it's not the mosquito in
section way and it's not the building
section wait so it's really the
spillover to humans that does not take
place
we now initially I started in mosquitoes
that would be the easier they didn't
walk so we started trapping birds and
looking at builds they didn't work
either links that we find level of
infection in bill
it is comparable to what's happening in
Chicago even in high infection years so
the spin over to human does not take
place when I moved to Atlanta it
occurred to me that the canopy seems to
be relatively high there's not as much
canopy on you know the intermediate and
low levels a lot of cliffs with heavily
canopy very high up and maybe a lot of
transmission happening there and it's
not spilling over down to the lower
level maybe maybe the diversity of avian
hosts are not important the different
climate and weather is in Atlanta so
it's out I don't have the answer just
yet we have some ideas about that but
it's still a little bit of Fame
surprising okay that's what I want to
say about West Nile virus I want to come
back and make a few points about them
generally about climate and them proper
genic trade and transmission I said
there are many examples that people talk
about the impact of climate change
malaria moving up the highlands in
sub-saharan Africa malaria are returning
to em temperate zones M dengue spreading
north and south specially in America
introduction of M Rift Valley fever
chikungunya into the u.s. chikungunya
already was introduced into Italy once
and they've recently been to papers
modeling modeling papers showing that
they're claiming there's a high
probability of chikungunya if it makes
it to be actually spread very well in
Atlanta and maybe even named in New York
Blue Tongue has moved up north in Europe
although some people say that is really
nothing to do with them climate change
and there's loud number of other you
know non vector borne diseases that are
highly impacted I liked it to be highly
impacted by changes in climate and by
changing other anthropogenic change and
really that's the point I really want to
you know make for a few more minutes
before I finish is that it's really
human population growth that is a single
driving factor it all scales
I know it's obvious you know but I think
we talked about climate change we talked
about urbanization we talked about heavy
habitats fragmentations about
deforestation so we for stations lot of
you know increase globalization of
Commerce and movement
and then all of the things really relate
to the fact that he knows that we have
you know more people and they directly
impose a live you know the fact that we
have so many people living in coastal
areas when there are much more
susceptible to the impact of climate
change especially extreme events so to
understand the impact of anthropogenic
changes including climate change on the
transmission of vector bonds or not you
see this I kind of echo what them Matt
was saying but a lot of stuff we don't
know yet in fact one of the thing I say
is if you really want to make
predictions about climate change and
transformation of a vector-borne
zoonosis do we really understand how
weather is impact the behavior of the
mosquito how vector is impact the
behavior of the weather well host or the
development of the virus or the portal
zone that we are looking at we really
have a thing to know much more about
those before we make predictions about
how changes in climate including the
complexity of those changes will impact
something as complex as transmission of
a vector bones or noses so we already
need to get better at assessing vector
and reservoir populations we need many
whoops keep doing it we need many more
long-term study when West Nile virus
came to New York every sphere it was a
good year for mosquitoes but there were
no data whatsoever in fact there was no
mosquito him so very nothing for over 20
years in EM in New York and after West
Nile virus tunnels there was some more
funding for surveillance of mosquitoes
and mosquito-borne diseases and I think
you know I'm sure same Ben beard can
testify that died down as you know they
kind of got used to having West Nile
virus you know so it in a way West Nile
virus with a nice opportunity it's a
relatively not a very serious disease
you know it had seol impact but compared
to this valley fever others it's not
that serious it was a perfect warning
call for us to really you know make get
our surveillance system going support
this kind of long term research but that
hasn't really happened which is part of
human nature we don't know enough about
pathogen transmission they
dynamic we need to consider also multi
parasite systems and I think that is
actually changing people are realizing
that rather than studies single parasite
it makes sense to static polic
parasitism and that is actually to me an
exciting development we need to consider
their so about that the spatial and
temporal skeletor Genuity we need to
better you know as all the years and in
general i think we have to better
understand their unchanging associations
between climate landscape weather and
the complex and components of vector
bones and other diseases and again I
think f2p already showed the vectorial
capacity but that's one example I mean
do we really know
can we really measure do really
understand how different components of
climate and weather will impact the
different M terms of the vectorial
capacity population size blood feeding
habits survival shape vector competence
and then for the person James huddle
survive and amplify human social
economic factors reservoir host we
actually don't really have an equivalent
equation to the vectorial capacity for
the weather or capacity there are some
that we don't were not there yet and of
course the actual transmission between
the vector where the world and the
spillover to humans so I think some key
questions that remain unanswered is what
would be the impact of climate change
and variation on vector on whether
population on exposure and all those
relationship Universal and if not how do
they vary locally and how can we assess
and incorporate their toward unity of
scale in time and space so the request
means how to better apply climate data
and models to transmission studies and
disease management system and the
conclusion I think already said that
climate change can work in both ways but
other support genic chain saw it equally
important and we really have to
interpret modeling studies cautiously
before they use to forecast changes in
vector and whole circulation and I think
alley be so on and I'm done
you